the Joe Rogan experience if there is a
Mount Rushmore of videogames your George
Washington you're up there so this is
great people have been kind of nudging
us from years and years to get this done
so it's great that we're finally able to
make it happen yeah I'm I have been from
day one a gigantic quake junkie and a
doom junkie so for me to have you in
here is a giant treat and everybody you
know I've talked about your video games
and your creations so many times on this
podcast so it's it's very cool to have
you here and thank you very much for
showing me before the podcast got
started I should tell everybody you
showed me the latest and greatest
version of oculus rift which is amazing
it's so small for people watching the
YouTube this is the entire unit this
this thing that sits on your head it's
very light and it's not attached to a
computer like you don't have to carry
anything around and there's no extra
everything is in here yeah so this is
the oculus quest the standalone device
and it's been kind of the culmination of
a bunch of different products that we've
been working on and it's the vision that
we had even six years ago just the idea
of not connected to anything you put
this magic hat on and you're transported
to these different worlds and this is
available right now anyone can buy this
right yeah okay so it's about the Jamie
just actually pulled all right the
website okay push this up to you pull
there you go um how what is the battery
life on these things so it depends on
what you're doing where I if you just
sit there and watch Netflix I you know
it'll last a little more than three
hours if you play some of the really
hardcore games it might only last two
hours or so do you have numbers on how
many people are watching Netflix on this
thing so our previous one right before
this the oculus go was a little bit more
media focused and that's one of our more
popular applications I mean surprisingly
things everybody thought that VR was
going to be all about these just amazing
gaming experiences but some of the most
popular experiences are doing reasonably
conventional things watching Netflix
watching YouTube Amazon Prime stuff like
that where if you're like if you're you
and you've got a great home theater and
everything there's not this much benefit
to having a theater like that in VR but
if you're in a situation like you're in
a tiny room in Tokyo or something the
idea of being able to put on the VR
headset and have
of this like lovely ski lodge atmosphere
with a giant screen TV it has some real
benefits so in the end VR should be a
replacement for anything you do on
screens today whether it's your phone
your tablet your TV your laptop your PC
all of these should eventually be
superseded by just having more flexible
screens in VR and we have lots of
challenges now with resolution and
comfort for long term use but this is
the direction that everything's going
not only do you have things in VR that
you couldn't do anywhere else just
experiences that you can't have with
that level of immersion but it should
pull along every other thing that people
do with screens devices today that's I
didn't consider the television shows but
of course people would be watching
Netflix on this if it's possible have
you done the Disney World ride the
Avatar ride flights of passage no I
haven't done that yet it's amazing
you sit on this it's like a motorcycle
looking thing it straps you in place and
it's supposed to represent one of those
flying dragon things in Avatar and then
you have the headset you put that on and
the virtual reality experience is second
to none I mean it's incredible
super-high resolution and the motorcycle
is moving around you get wind and smells
and all these sensors yeah so that's one
of the really interesting things like I
think about that whenever I am at
amusement parks for things like the
Harry Potter rides and stuff like that
where they're doing lots with screens
and motion platforms where I think about
it from the VR perspective and anything
we're doing visually and audibly we
could go ahead and do a great job in the
headset so it's cutting it down to these
few physical things that you can't do so
you've got things with motion platforms
that actually jostle you around that you
can't do in VR you've got things like
smell and like the void I'm where they
have the Star Wars experience there we
have a fantastic Star Wars experience on
quest which in many ways has a lot of
that magic but in the void where they
set it up and they blow hot air over
what's the virtual lava I toured zyou
that's something that you still don't
get but it's kind of like the age-old
battle of what can you do differently in
an arcade that you can't do as good in
your your home system and VR now takes
lets you do all of these amazing things
there but if you're willing to spend
millions of dollars and build a theme
park attraction essentially you can
still throw some of these extra things
and people joke about when is
smellivision coming to VR and there have
actually been real companies that have
spun up to say it's like well we want to
do send augmentation it's not a great
thing and those are still the last
vestiges of things where you have to go
someplace but the promise of VR is to
you know the world as you want it not
having to go to someplace to do
something magical and if you can get to
90 something percent of that experience
staying in your own room then that's
great what would they be able to do with
smellivision would you have like a
standalone unit that like has access to
the program so like if you were flying
over orange fields it would spray citrus
in the air so sort of like soaring over
the world have you ever done that
Disneyland rocket so somebody literally
did make this where they made a little
box that put that glue to attach to the
underside of the head-mounted display
and one of the interesting things about
sent as opposed to I like audio or video
with video everybody knows that you just
make red green and blue colors you can
mix them in any way and make all the
colors that we can see smell isn't like
that I am our nose is actually a
receptor for a whole lot of discrete
different molecules there's no way to
mix up smell like the way we do with
light to make red green and blue
primaries with that so they really had
to pick okay here's the dozen or so
smells that we're going to have with
this and it would just sort of spritz it
out on a little blast of air I very
close to your nose so it doesn't need
much of it to get in hmm so if you
really wanted to do some sort of a
jungle experience with you know
thousands of different smells of plants
and dirt and although you would have to
have like some enormous unit that's
spraying these various things yeah
although I suspect that at least modern
people in modern society do not really
have that discerning of a level of scent
like if you took I some Peruvian
indigent or something that they probably
would complain it's like all the
fidelity on this is garbage I should
have 500 different smells here and I
only detect five right but you take you
know a normal City person and you just
three scents of jungle is probably going
to be more than enough to sell the
experience yeah the guy in the jungle
bill
this is sterile urine yeah that's not
real so what is this Jamie oh my
goodness so this is something she's
holding I know I get it she's pulled it
off it attaches to the headset it says
feel real yeah
sensory mask so it's a sensory mass that
smell virtual reality oh yeah it's so it
simulates simulates hundreds of smells
to immerse you in the virtual world Wow
of course it's coming but why am i
shocked look at this guy's got like a
little cartridge just pop it in there
all the refilling your toner cartridge
ah how reliable scent generator how
hilarious but yes if you have if you
have to rank your senses that's not in
the top two yeah it's probably gonna be
clunky like the earlier versions of VR
where you got that low resolution sort
of thing I remember my friend Duncan
he's he's a huge technology freak and he
had a really early version of the
consumer virtual reality headsets the
early early oculus and I remember
putting it on going oh my god even
though it's really pixelated like this
is a game changer it that sense that
you've seen the future yeah you put it
on it's like it's not here yet but
that's the the ability to just project a
little bit past the flaws there and say
okay well we're gonna sort this out over
the next several years
we'll get higher resolution we'll get
the response better and you can imagine
what it's going to be yeah it's pretty
stunning and what you just showed me
today the the Star Wars one is actually
higher resolution than the void which is
the one that you pay to go see or you go
into the warehouse and everything I've
done that several times the void with
Star Wars and then the void with
wreck-it Ralph which is pretty cool too
it's really fun but the physicality of
having the actual props there is the
magic of being in there it's like you
pull out your stormtrooper blaster and
you have get around and that's really
something versus a lot of times when
you're just using the controllers to
pretend you're doing things you feel
like you're a mime some place some
French mime kind of pretending to do
things and that doesn't sell the
experience and that's why I've you know
my favorites are the things like beat
Sabre we're in the game you are swinging
this lightsaber is sort of think through
things so your actions in reality are
exact
what your actions in the virtual world
are you swing through it there's a
little bit of a buzz as you cross
through it and it just feels like you
are you're projecting yourself there